welcome back everyone today's video is
going to be about ranking up your
weapons and Titans in titanfall 2 so
that you can get them to the next
generation faster get the new camo is
complete all the challenges and just
overall get enough credits to bore to
buy more Titans and weapons to make your
experience of this game more fun now
it's kind of self-explanatory but I'd
still rather go over it just in case no
one really knows and that's completely
fine but the first thing I'm going to be
talking about right now is the weapons
the way to rank up weapons in titanfall
2 are pretty easy you basically get
kills by killing pilots if you play
attrition and you kill grunts vectors or
Reapers they do not count sadly but if
you kill a pilot with your weapon it
does count if you get an assist
it also does count which is very nice
and it's kind of that's really it
there's nothing much really to explain I
think the best game-mode you should be
playing as pilots versus pilots seeing
as there's no Titans to get in your way
and everyone's on even ground with all
what with only just weapons so it's kind
of fair and it's really easy the next
I'm going to be talking about though is
the Titans for the Titans the best way
to rank up the Titans in titanfall 2 is
by destroying other Titans for example
if you're fighting another Titan you
happen to get into a doom state and you
do get that you do get xp for getting it
into a doom state but you need to
destroy it needs to come up in the kill
feed that you destroyed the Titan if you
destroyed the Titan you get a point if
you destroy the pilot you get a point if
you if you do both I'm pretty sure you
get two points towards your next level
up another way that you can get more XP
towards your Titan is by being the first
to fall being the first to fall means
you're the first person to call on your
Titan not earn it but earn it and call
it in first
you can also assist your teammates by
giving them batteries that will also
rank up your
by doing multitudes of challenges well
both by the way ranking up weapons and
Titans also helps with or the challenges
also help with ranking them up as well
but I recommend for the Titans to play
last Titan standing see has there's no
pilots yes the pilot can get out of the
Titan but it's mostly a Titan versus
Titan game-mode now if you're like me
and you want both of them to be ranked
up at the same time a recommended game
mode is more attrition or if you're
really not feeling attrition then you
might want to do capture the flag both
of those game modes really help in
ranking up weapons and Titans I have
I've already had two weapons at Gen 2
and I already have one of the Titans
already Jen - almost Gen 3 because I've
been playing these game modes so there's
proof that these work overall this is
just a really small video nothing huge
nothing like a 10 minute long video
there's no need for that which is basic
stuff but regardless though hope you did
enjoy super small video like I said just
like the video if you enjoyed comment
your opinion and also comment if I
missed anything that I should have added
also one note I noticed on the last
video while I'm making this I have about
120 views on my unlimited merit video I
want to say if you were a person that
watched that video I love you because
that is the first video on this channel
to ever break over a hundred views Zach
especially that quickly - and I just I
was so happy when I woke up today and
saw that I'm eternally grateful so thank
you all for that but you know like
comment sub all that stuff for the like
go let's try to get some 5 likes you
know some small [ __ ] not looking for
stuff not looking for much but thank you
guys in a piece out have a great day